bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
notre grand témoin ce soir et l'un des
principaux auteurs du dernier rapport du
GIEC bonsoir François Germaine et merci
d'être avec nous c'est le fruit de la
synthèse des 8 années de travaux des 93
scientifiques du GIEC on va y revenir
dans le détail le constat on le connaît
il est implacable sur le dérèglement
climatique mais il y a de l'espoir et
même quelques fenêtres de tirs on va y
venir dans le détail tout à l'heure mais
on commence avec cette question en
pleine crise des retraites faut-il
supprimer le 49,3 depuis Elisabeth borne
elle a déclenché le mouvement dans la
rue a changé de nature à la colère
sociale s'est ajoutée la défiance la
crise démocratique et on sent bien et
bien que les citoyens n'ont plus
confiance dans nos institutions alors
comment réparer la cinquième république
est-elle à bout de souffle grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris bien sûr
et puis Bourbon express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le menu ce soir vous me suivez
François Germaine et bien c'est parti
[Musique]
et si c'était lui le problème le 49-3
dans notre Constitution permet au
gouvernement d'engager sa responsabilité
sur un texte de loi pour l'adopter sans
vote ou illégal bien sûr déjà utilisé
100 fois depuis le début de la cinquième
république mais de plus en plus un
supportable aux yeux des Français en
témoignent la colère et même les
violences que sont déclenchement à
provoqué bonsoir Jérémy Yordanov et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
députés Europe Écologie Les Verts vous
étiez dans les cortèges contre la
réforme des retraites et vous avez
déposé une proposition doit pour
supprimer le 49.3 de la Constitution
c'était quelques jours avant son
déclenchement va y revenir et vous avez
aussi lancé une pétition qui a recueilli
plus de 190 000 signatures à ce jour
bonsoir Bruno ketel ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
ancien député la République en marche de
l'Eure dans la précédente législature et
vous avez retrouvé votre robe d'avocat
aujourd'hui bonsoir Christophe Barbier
grand plaisir de vous avoir à nouveau
parmi nous tutorialiste politique à BFM
TV et à Franck tireur enfin bonsoir Paul
Cassia bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
droit public à l'université parisien
Panthéon Sorbonne François Germaine
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez je sais que cette crise des
retraites vous intéresse on a quatre
experts et puis on a un nouvel expert et
c'est évidemment Stéphane Stéphane Da
kowski dans ce débat il va nous dire
pourquoi au fond aujourd'hui il y a un
avant et un après 49-3 c'est le chrono
de Blacko pour démarrer
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs alors l'expert 49-3 que nous
49 3 faut-il le rappeler ça fait
référence son troisième alinéa du 49e
article de la Constitution donc si vous
voulez le lire la fiché mais tout le
monde connaît le principe ça permet donc
au gouvernement de faire adopter un
projet de loi sans faire voter les
députés alors évidemment ça se suicide
du débat il y a ceux qui vous diront que
c'est un déni de démocratie et d'autres
qui répondront oui c'est quand même un
outil indispensable pour gouverner cela
dit dans ce genre de débat faut
reconnaître que le point de vue des uns
et des autres est très différent selon
qu'ils sont dans l'opposition ou au
gouvernement on peut prendre l'exemple
de François Hollande par exemple qui
était dans l'opposition en 2006 et qui
critiquait 49-3 quand Dominique Villepin
a utilisé pour faire pour faire adopter
le CPE on l'écoute le 49.3 est une
brutalité le 49.3 est un déni de
démocratie le 49-3 est une manière de
freiner d'EMP le débat parlementaire
alors évidemment ce qui est savoureux
dans cet extrait c'est que 10 ans plus
tard une fois élu président François
Hollande n'a laissé Emmanuel Valls qui
était son premier ministre utilisait à
plusieurs reprises le 49-3 et pour vous
dire comme les revirements sont assez
fréquents sur le sujet du 49-3 une fois
qui lui qui était Matignon et bien
Manuel Valls avait complètement changé
de vie sur le 49-3 quand il se
présentait à la primaire de la gauche on
écoute
le proposerai que hors texte budgétaire
parce que la nation a besoin d'un budget
je proposerai de supprimer purement et
simplement le 49-3 bref tout ça nous
rappelle que ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
l'opposition écrite le 49-3 pourraient
très bien être amené à l'utiliser si
exactement ça c'est déjà vu vous venez
de le rappeler l'usage du 49-3 n'est pas
si rare 100 fois déjà utilisé depuis le
début de la 5e République et on sait que
celui qui l'a pu s'utiliser c'est Michel
Rocard le record est à 28 parce qu'il
n'avait pas de majorité absolue
exactement comme Emmanuel pardon comme
Elisabeth borne et d'ailleurs
lorsqu'elle a fait adopter sa réforme
des retraites 49-3 bien à la tribune à
la Cité Michel Rocard les maux de Rocard
lorsque lui a fait adopter la CSG au
49-3 on écoute
Michel Rocard avait eu ses mots dans un
scrutin où chacun à votre es selon sa
conscience
permettez-moi de dire que je suis sûr
que ces dispositions réuniraient une
majorité peut-être même une large
majorité donc voilà effectivement le
meilleur argument sans doute en faveur
du 49 toi c'est qui le permet au
gouvernement d'échapper aux certains
calculs politiciens peuvent avoir les
députés en l'occurrence Elizabeth borne
elle parlait des LR qui après avoir
défendu la retraite à 65 ans refusait de
la voter quand elle passait à 64
pourtant même si la première ministre
estime avoir remporté une victoire sur
la réforme des retraites gaz 49-3 on
peut quand même en douter depuis que la
réforme a été adoptée au 49-3 il y a eu
les événements de la Concorde puis tous
les soirs des débordements de violents
où on a le sentiment que la compote 3 a
joué un rôle en tout cas elle était
prévenue c'est exactement ce que disait
Laurent Berger avant qu'il utilise le
49-3
moi je pense que on peut pas je vous le
redis avoir un tel mobilisation une
telle une telle opinion qui est adverse
qui est contre cette réforme une
procédure parlementaire escamotée et
avoir un vice démocratique par le vote
de cette réforme par un recours à 43
enfin je pense que ce serait extrêmement
extrêmement dangereux dans le
ressentiment que ça pourrait ça pourrait
créer alors vous savez là on est sur
celui qui sont pour ou contre la réforme
mais il y a pas de Laurent Berger qui
soit critique vis-à-vis du 49.3 je vais
vous faire écouter Nicolas Sarkozy elle
s'est bien placé pour en parler puisque
c'est lui qui a réduit l'usage du 49-3
en 2008 il est invité un congrès sur les
institutions au mois d'octobre et il
expliquait pourquoi en 2010 lorsqu'il a
fait adopter cette réforme des retraites
alors que François Fillon Premier
ministre et Bernard cahier président de
l'Assemblée lui demander de la faire
passer cette réforme au 49 fois pourquoi
il avait dit non en écoute malgré tout
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale au
Parlement au Sénat
c'est un peu comme si vous voulez la
vapeur dans la cocotte-minute
si vous listez sortir un peu de vapeur
c'est mieux pour ne pas risquer
l'explosion ah voilà c'était mieux pour
éviter l'explosion ben voilà il paraît
que le président Macron parle souvent
avec son prédécesseur Nicolas Sarkozy
peut-être que sur ce sujet il aurait pu
tenir compte des conseils de son
prédécesseur mais il y a des bas merci
merci pour ce billet très complet ce
soir Paul cassias je vais commencer avec
vous un peu d'histoire peut-être comment
il est né comment il a été pensé par le
général de Gaulle et par Michel Debré ce
49-3 par les auteurs de la Constitution
il s'insère dans un ensemble qu'on
appelle le parlementarisme rationalisé
l'idée c'est de ne pas retomber dans les
Hermans de la Quatrième République et de
faire en sorte que le gouvernement
puisse gouverner et il y a dans la
Constitution un nombre assez
impressionnant de mécanismes qui
permettent précisément à l'exécutif de
mener la politique qu'il souhaite en
dépit de contraintes diverses qui
peuvent tenir soit à l'obstruction
parlementaire soit au fait de ne pas
avoir de majorité absolue de 49 3 pour
débloquer alors qu'on est majoritaire un
mur d'amendement de l'opposition ou pour
passer un texte sans majorité absolument
et dans l'histoire il y a plus de
déblocage ou de passage en force ça doit
se tenir entre les deux entre les deux
rives mais ce qui est tout à fait
original dans la dans la dans le
contexte actuel et vous l'avez dit en
commençant Myriam c'est que le 49-3 est
apparu un supportable pourquoi parce que
on a un concentré de tous les mécanismes
parlementaires qui sont favorables à
l'exécutif qui ont été utilisés dans une
période très courte de quelques 50 jours
à peu près là qui est plus insupportable
parce qu'il arrive après déjà des
procédures qui ont contraint voir
cadenacer le débat c'est ça c'est mon
sentiment vous êtes d'accord avec ça
Christophe Barbier ce 49,3 là et plus
dur à avaler que les autres oui bien sûr
pour deux raisons d'abord l'accumulation
des procédures c'est vrai que 47 1 44 3
au Sénat 49.3 ça faisait beaucoup et
pour une raison aussi plus profonde à
mon avis c'est que le gouvernement quand
même depuis le 10 janvier n'a cessé de
dire on ne veut pas de 49-3 bon il est
là bien sûr on ne peut pas l'exclure
mais on ne veut pas notre volonté c'est
une majorité politique on discute avec
les LR jusqu'au dimanche précédent où le
patron du parti de la majorité
présidentielle Stéphane séjourné donne
une interview pour dire nous ne voulons
pas du 49.3 et le revirement entre la
poire et le fromage le jeudi midi avec
une première ministre qui arrive en
retard parce que le 49-3 en catastrophe
dans la panique est utilisé ça le
délégitime aux yeux des parlementaires
de la majorité qui ont été frustrés
choqués aux yeux des oppositions et aux
yeux de l'opinion
tout le temps dire dire que c'est un
déni de démocratie c'est faux c'est dans
la Constitution Sénégal et donc légitime
est-ce que cette conséquence du légal au
légitime et si évidente c'est la
légitimité juridique mais une légitimité
dans notre vie moderne c'est plein
d'autres choses c'est la légitimité
politique vos alliés c'est la légitimité
aussi parfois d'époque est-ce qu'on va
dans le sens de l'histoire ou pas très
difficile très subjectif après venir
dire que parce que 70% des Français sont
contre une réforme elle ne doit pas être
votée ça c'est autre chose ou basculer
dans une démocratie d'opinion c'est une
autre forme de régime en même temps
Nicolas Sarkozy avant la crise des
retraites il avait déjà limité la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 c'est
1 49-3 par session parlementaire oui du
budget oui ce qui est déjà difficile à
comprendre que le président Sarkozy
savait que c'était plus possible de
l'utiliser il fallait faire gaffe il
faut faire attention effectivement puis
je crois qu'il y a un écueil
supplémentaire dans le sujet de la
réforme des retraites actuelles c'est
que nos compatriotes sont beaucoup plus
aguerris des questions politiques qu'on
pourrait le croire et tout ce constatent
que les députés ne se sont pas prononcés
sur ce texte finalement
puisque le débat a été interrompu dans
le cadre de l'application du 47 ans en
première lecture
et là le vote de censure n'est voté que
par les députés de l'opposition donc les
députés de la majorité n'ont même pas eu
à faire l'acte de voter la réforme
de la cinquième ou un texte est adopté
par 49-3 mais sans même qu'il y ait eu
un seul vote à l'Assemblée nationale
on n'est pas allé très loin à
l'Assemblée il y a eu un vote au Sénat
quand même il y avait une base que
d'ailleurs la CMP la Commission
mixparitaire a reprises donc il y avait
pas rien non plus comme
pour les députés il y avait une
frustration la souveraineté nationale
appartient au peuple qui l'exerce par la
voie de ses représentants et là les
représentants n'ont pas pu l'exercice
tout à fait je crois que ça pose aussi
un coin dans l'appréhension de
l'utilisation du 43
très bien compris qu'il n'y avait pas de
majorité sur ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale et quand je vous entendais
dire tout à l'heure démocratie d'opinion
c'est pas possible mais là c'est que la
démocratie n'a pas pu s'exprimer
j'ajoute qu'elle est ça veut dire quoi
déni parce que il y a des députés et non
des moindres comme Charles de Courson
qui a été député depuis 30 ans ici à
l'assemblée qui dit déni démocratie il a
dit à la tribune Laurent Berger lui dit
vice-démocratique d'autres disent c'est
démocratique donc
anti-démocratique mais en tout cas c'est
une vision de la démocratie qui est très
particulière qui est très
franco-française qui consiste à dire
c'est le président de la République qui
a la légitimité et l'Assemblée nationale
et le Parlement de manière générale
c'est un peu pénible ça nous fatigue
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron l'a dit dans
son interview il a dit on va faire moins
de loi on va faire des décrets je trouve
que c'est symptomatique de d'une dérive
de la Cinquième République et là où il
n'a pas compris c'est que la société
française a changé et nous avons besoin
de plus de délibération de plus de
démocratie je pense je rejoins l'analyse
qui a été faite tout à l'heure sur
des 47 ans etc qui fait qu'à la fin
c'est pas acceptable je vais ajouter une
autre chose c'est que l'article 49 à son
alinéa premier dit le gouvernement
engage sa responsabilité devant
l'Assemblée nationale et les habitants
n'a pas engagé sa responsabilité devant
l'Assemblée nationale et non et donc
c'est aussi un objet de ma proposition
de loi c'est
pour modifier la Constitution pour dire
le gouvernement doit engager dans toutes
les démocraties parlementaires c'est
comme ça que ça se passe il faut un vote
de confiance que vous avez dit
expliquez-nous parce que si elle avait
été censurée le gouvernement tombé c'est
ça l'équilibre
mais le 49 alinéa premier c'est le
gouvernement quand il est mis en place
et en fait elle aurait dû à ce moment-là
s'assurer d'avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale ça n'a pas été
fait et là où ces problématique c'est
que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été élu sur
son programme il a été élu moi j'ai
appelé à voter pour lui et j'ai voté
pour lui parce que je voulais battre
Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national donc son mandat c'est aussi de
battre le rassemblement national c'est
pas forcément de faire son programme et
donc derrière s'ils ne s'assure pas
d'avoir une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale évidemment ça va poser un
problème dans le déroulé si vous voulez
de son action politique comme député
vous voulez supprimer le 49-3 contre la
réforme des retraites ou de la
constitution de façon définitive de la
constitution de façon définitive moi
j'ai un problème avec la c'est un client
République parce que je considère
qu'elle n'est pas assez parlementaire
elle ne donne pas assez de poids à la
délibération au rôle des députés et des
sénateurs et donc il y a plusieurs
mécanismes qu'il faudrait changer
celui-ci il est assez facile à changer
il ne change pas il ne bouleverse pas
les équilibres parce qu'il reste le 49-2
qui est la motion censure il reste le
pouvoir de dissolution il reste le 49-1
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement il reste sur les lois
budgétaires l'article 47 et 47 1 qui
permet en cas de blocage de passer par
ordonnance donc ça ne pose pas ça ne
créera pas de blocage tout le monde a
compris que c'était un problème et on le
voit aujourd'hui c'est un problème
politique dans la rue donc je pense que
c'est quelque chose assez facile à
changer on connaît pas tous la
Constitution par cœur mais c'est
intéressant donc on pourrait le
supprimer tout en restant dans la
cinquième république ça obligerait quoi
ça obligerait en cas de majorité
relative la première ministre a
systématiquement ou le Premier ministre
a trouvé des compromis c'est ça
absolument ça serait une arme lisant
l'arme nucléaire du parlementarisme
rationalisé qui qui disparaîtrait de
l'arsenal de l'exécutif d'accord donc on
changerait pas la République l'arme
nucléaire il faut tout faire pour pas
s'en servir mais c'est quand même mieux
de la posséder parce que la cinquième
son ADN c'est quand même l'efficacité
l'efficience par rapport à l'impuissance
de la quatrième donc il faut qu'à un
moment donné l'exécutif puisse avancer
quel que soit la situation législative
et donc autant il faut en encadrer
l'usage c'est déjà fait en grande partie
et surtout éduquer les gouvernants à ne
pas considérer le 43 comme une banalité
autant je pense qu'il faut le laisser
parce qu'on passerait dans une autre
République que la cinquième on
enlèverait cet ADN de l'efficience le
49-3 doit pouvoir rester là en revanche
il faut en avoir une sorte de d'hygiène
de 49-3 si Elisabeth borne était venu le
10 janvier en disant écoutez cette
réforme c'est une réforme de droite
c'est ce que la droite réclame depuis
longtemps je demande donc au groupe
élèves de la voter attention si vous me
faites défaut si pour des du billard à
12 bandes internes ou des raisons
politiciennes vous me rejoignez pas sur
ce texte je prendrai le 49-3 et de
Gaulle m'applaudira depuis sa tombe bon
déjà
Houellebecq hygiène du 49-3 vous y
croyez pas
il faudrait supprimer à votre avis je
pense effectivement qu'il y a un gros
besoin je suis pas du tout
constitutionnalisme mais je pense qu'il
y a effectivement dans la Cinquième
République il y a un poids parfois
démesuré qui est donné à l'exécutif et
je pense qu'une nécessité de
rééquilibrage et pouvoir on l'a dit on
l'a dit d'ailleurs au moment des des
premiers députés en match on a parlé de
députés godillot etc et quelque part
c'était une sorte d'insultes son rôle du
Parlement et je pense que c'est
l'intérêt d'une démocratie moderne et
efficace d'avoir un parlement qui joue
pleinement son rôle y compris son rôle
de contre-pouvoir par rapport à
l'exécutif le 49-3 est souvent brandi
pour les gouvernants par les
gouvernements disant oui mais c'est pour
faire débloquer les obstructions est-ce
que vous seriez d'accord pour mettre
dans la Constitution qu'on est
parlementaires n'ont droit qu'à un
amendement chacun par texte ou 10 vous
voyez à zéro amendement
parce que l'arme nucléaire du député
mais c'est l'obstruction donc voilà je
suis d'accord que l'obstruction ça fait
pas avancer le débat mais le problème
c'est que quand l'Assemblée nationale
n'a aucun pouvoir qu'est-ce qui nous
reste il faut te faire entendre d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est pas c'est
pas pour c'est pas pour dire que c'est
bien l'obstruction moi c'est pas c'est
pas ma façon de faire mais je pense que
il faut de manière générale renforcée
quand même
l'Assemblée nationale on va venir à la
question institutionnelle et revenir à
ce que proposait Emmanuel Macron pendant
sa campagne mais je vous laisse terminer
Bruno Quetel la Cinquième République
c'est quand même un équilibre entre
double une double légitimité qu'on nous
apprend à en première année de droit le
suffrage universel pour le président de
la République le suffrageait universel
pour l'Assemblée nationale et ça doit
s'équilibrer avec des mécanismes soit de
la censure soit de la dissolution s'il y
a une difficulté et tout ça il faut
faire attention à pouvoir préserver une
forme d'équilibre parce que ce que vous
préconisez le retour parlementarisme
type 4e République pour être clair parce
que je pense que dans votre esprit de la
5e République et la question de la
suppression d'élection suffrage
universelle qui vient du président de la
République suivre votre cohérence ça
déstabilise tout je sais pas si notre
pays est préfère ça et je voudrais juste
pour conclure ça fait 30 ans que le
système institutionnel se délite
2002 Jacques Chirac 82 % aucune
conséquence 2005 le référendum deux ans
après le traité de Lisbonne ça fait non
pas 30 ans mais 20 ans que les
Françaises et les Français considèrent
que les politiques ne respectent pas
leur voix donc là on va y venir ça c'est
la question de la de la représentation
et de la confiance vous connaissez bien
cette question d'ailleurs je voulais
vous poser la question parce que
vous-même pendant la crise des gilets
jaunes vous étiez député à l'Assemblée
ça a été très compliqué il y a eu des
coups de feu devant votre domicile ça a
été paroxysme de violence avec le recul
qu'est-ce que vous tirez comme
enseignement de ce point de rupture en
fait entre entre une partie des Français
et leurs élus mais l'expression le mode
d'expression de la défiance est
différent la violence les réseaux
sociaux et autres mais la défiance c'est
depuis 20 ans toujours là dès le
lendemain d'une élection nationale on
prétend contester le résultat des ions
dès lors on y retrouve pas son propre
compte et je crois qu'il faut aussi
faire un gros travail de c'est la
question citoyenne qu'il faut
retravailler tout un chacun doit
reprendre sa place dans le débat public
dans l'expression du citoyen à la
décision pour y trouver son compte en
tant que personne
électrices électeurs qui se considère
aujourd'hui non respectées et c'est ça
qu'il faut travailler on va voir
justement c'est les institutions ou
c'est la participation on va revoir un
petit peu avec Thibault inok ce que
proposait Emmanuel Macron en 2017 en
2022 sur les institutions
Emmanuel Macron et les institutions ou
une histoire contrariée la réforme de
notre mode de scrutin est une nécessité
promesse de campagne de 2017 la réforme
des institutions voulu pendant le
premier quinquennat prévoyait une
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
une part de proportionnelle et une
limitation du cumul des mandats dans le
temps un parlement moins nombreux mais
renforcé dans ses moyens autant
d'ambition qui n'aboutiront pas l'examen
du texte est suspendu en juillet 2018 en
raison de l'affaire Benalla un nouveau
texte plus restreint est à nouveau
présenté un an plus tard il ne sera
jamais discuté faute d'accord politique
Emmanuel Macron n'a pourtant pas dit son
dernier mot une réforme des institutions
reste à son agenda depuis le début de
l'année le président consulte la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
le président du Sénat ont été reçus pour
évoquer le sujet tout comme Nicolas
Sarkozy et François Hollande parmi les
pistes de cette nouvelle réforme
constitutionnelle deux idées de départ
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
et la part de proportionnelle sont
toujours d'actualité le chef de l'État
réfléchirait aussi à un passage au
septennat non renouvelable couplé
peut-être à des élections législatives
de mi-mandat enfin il souhaiterait
revoir l'organisation et le découpage
des collectivités territoriales
autant le dire tout de suite à ce stade
de la crise cette réforme n'a aucune
chance de voir le jour parce qu'il
faudrait 3/5 des parlementaires pour
l'adopter mais est-ce qu'il y a de
bonnes choses dans le diagnostic et les
réponses données sur la crise
démocratique Myriam il faudrait pas trop
à cinquième des parlementaires pour une
des réformes importantes qui vient
d'être évoquée celle de la
proportionnelle puisque une loi simple
suffirait parce que les députés soient
élus à la représentation proportionnelle
je rappelle ici que en février 2017
lorsque François Pérou s'est rallye à
Emmanuel Macron l'un des trois
engagements qui avait été pris par
Emmanuel Macron c'était d'instaurer la
proportionnelle ce qu'il n'a pas fait
alors même je pense que le contrôle de
Monsieur le Député kettle qu'il avait
tout à fait la majorité suffisante pour
cela lors du quinquennat précédent et ce
point là est quand même assez grave et
d'entendre encore parler de
proportionnelle aujourd'hui je dois dire
que c'est passablement agaçant puisque
chaque
pourquoi pour quelle raison ça a été
enterré la proportionnelle
parce que je pense que c'est facile
d'avoir il s'est dit je vais encore
avoir une majorité
large tout seul et j'ai pas besoin de la
proportionnelle ça va être ça va être
pénible
qui revient
sur ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
qui a été déporté juste une petite
précision sur l'élection directe du
président de la République ce n'est pas
la Constitution de 1958 c'est le
référendum de 1962 donc quand on dit ça
va changer les grands équilibre non la
constitution de 58 elle a été rédigée
pour qu'un président de la République ne
vienne pas contester la légitimité des
parlementaires qui eux aussi sont élus
aussi fragile universel direct vous
voyez donc
je comprends bien le président de la
République devrait être responsable
devant le Parlement aujourd'hui il est
responsable il est tout-puissant d'une
certaine façon et pas responsable devant
sa majorité il faudrait revenir
il ne peut pas faire abstraction dans
tous les cas de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est ça que je dis c'est que
l'Assemblée nationale a aussi une
légitimité et quand on l'entend on a
l'impression qu'il dit moi j'ai été élu
je suis légitime et le reste ça n'existe
pas et ça c'est problématique et je
pense que la proportionnel réglerait une
partie du problème parce que
l'ensemble des opinions disons pourrait
s'exprimer à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale et moi je pense que si on veut
éviter la confrontation dans ce pays il
faut que le débat d'opinion d'idées la
délibération se fasse dans les
institutions
dont vous avez le plus débattu dans
l'histoire de la réforme du système des
retraites depuis une trentaine d'années
donc ne dites pas qu'on a pas débattu
beaucoup de temps semble avoir été perdu
en écueil et incident de séance mais sur
le fond je crois qu'il y a plus de 150
heures de débats il y a trois ans de
débats il y a le sujet ça a été rappelé
il est sur la table depuis 2017 ne dites
pas objectivement qu'il y a pas eu de
débat maintenant c'est la manière dont
le débat est mené la manière dont les
uns et les autres se posent qui peut qui
peuvent interroger à chaque crise c'est
systématiquement la figure du président
de la République qui est ciblé et qui
est
[Musique]
anticiper cohabitation Chirac Mitterrand
par exemple mais au moins ça permettait
aux député de se concentrer avec le
gouvernement sur la politique de c'est
le président présidé là on a tiré le
président vers le quotidien et on a un
députés vers une tension pour ou contre
le président alors la proportionnelle
oui pour représenter même si en effet là
on a une assemblée représentative sans
proportionnelle ça a deux défaut quand
même le risque de paralysie avec des
gouvernements qui tombent qui trouve
jamais de majorité syndrome 4e moi je
vois un autre défaut quand vous êtes élu
après une campagne les pieds dans la
boue de 150 voix vous allez retrouver à
l'Assemblée votre collègue qui lui aura
été élu sur la part proportionnelle
désigné par son parti en ayant fait
campagne dans les sur les plateaux télés
dans les canapés de
Saint-Germain-des-Prés vous aurez des
députés à deux vitesses à deux
légitimités vous croyez que le premier
va accepter que l'autre soit président
de commission fasse passer ses
amendements et de temps en Allemagne
quand même Christophe Barbier c'est ce
qui a le bout de strat il y a le Bundes
il y a les Länders ça change beaucoup de
choses là on est dans la 5e
avec le Sénat Sena émanation des
territoires avec un système de grands
électeurs c'est une forme de légitimité
territoriale et assemblée et moi je suis
pour le maintien du suffrage universel
direct majoritaire à l'assemblée moi je
serai pour quelqu'un tour voilà on
s'entend avant il y a qu'un tour celui
qui arrive premier il était élu ça
obligerait les parties à faire des
alliances dès le premier tour et ce qui
a fait d'ailleurs un peu la nupestre la
dernière fois ce qui explique peut-être
aussi c'est bon résultat pour qu'on ait
quelque chose d'assez brutal en effet
mais d'efficace je pense que l'Assemblée
doit rester le lieu de l'efficacité ça
crée des coalitions avant le vote avant
si on fait la proportionnelle intégrale
ce que moi je propose je dépose un PPLC
parce que c'est pas effectivement un
test constitutionnel
ça fait les coalitions après et
l'ensemble du spectre politique est
représenté dans les institutions
de censure constructive on y arrive si
on veut pas l'instabilité il y a
beaucoup d'autres mécanismes regardez
Israël Israël non mais regardez regardez
la Belgique regarder l'Allemagne
regardez l'Italie regardez l'Espagne la
proportionnelle c'est pas quelque chose
de complètement extravagant on a déjà
une chambre qui représente les
territoires on peut très bien avoir une
chambre qui représente la nation qui est
élu à la porte on va pas vous mettre
d'accord parce que j'ai toujours les
mêmes arguments la stabilité contre la
représentativité absolument il y a un
élément du rapport du GIEC qui est tout
à fait intéressant et donc personne ne
parle c'est le comparatif régime
majoritaire versus régime
proportionnelle sur l'efficacité de
l'action climatique et qui montre que
les régimes proportionnels ont tendance
à être plus efficaces en matière
d'action climatique que les régimes
majoritaires à méditer on va se quitter
avec personne
en tout cas ceux qui nous
regardent se
feront activement
écouter Laurent Berger parce que
j'aimerais juste vous faire réagir ça
pourrait peut-être éventuellement offrir
une sortie de crise au président
je dis ce matin qu'il faut apaiser les
choses et je propose pour apaiser les
choses qui effectivement
attendez écoute un camp de dialogue et
qu'on mette sur pause sur la réforme des
retraites
mercredi vous nous avez parlé d'usure au
travail vous nous avez parlé d'emploi
des seniors vous nous avez parlé de
d'aménagement des fins de carrière
normalement tous ces sujets là ça
devrait être dans la réforme de retraite
donc on a mis la charrue avant les deux
tout le monde le sait ce qui le
mouvement social les manifestants hier
ils disent quoi ils disent mais faut
parler du travail et on reparle du
travail on va parler des retraites y
compris du déficit du système des
retraites mais pas de cette manière
c'est une main tendue une nouvelle main
tendue de Laurent Berger ont fait une
pause on remet les réformes à l'endroit
on discute de la loi travail en premier
et puis on suspend la réforme des
retraites une fois qu'on a trouvé un
compromis sur la pénibilité sur les
questions d'usure professionnelle de
toute façon si ma mémoire est bonne le
texte réformes retraite est applicable
au premier septembre 2023 je crois que
c'est s'il ne tombe pas devant le
conseil je suis pas là pour faire de la
politicienne donc premier septembre 2023
donc ça permet un temps de réflexion
vous avez la loi ordinaire effectivement
qui va venir et Laurent Berger a raison
c'est là où les fondamentaux doivent
être évoqués le temps de travail dans le
temps de vie le temps de formation
professionnelle la durée hebdomadaire du
temps de travail moi je suis un adepte
du principe de liberté par excellence si
des gens veulent moins travailler il
faut leur poser toutes les conséquences
venir sur le travail avant alors est-ce
que la pose sur les retraites n'est pas
utile pour pouvoir éventuellement sortir
de la crise je crois qu'il serait
bienvenu d'engager un débat de fond le
plus large possible et dans un consensus
à rechercher je trouve que la porte de
sortie
il devrait
[Musique]
de la prendre effectivement c'est la
moindre des choses c'est une porte de
sortie qui est honorable pour tout le
monde et aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut
pas en tout cas continuer comme si de
rien n'était dernier mot sur la question
de la participation vous en avez parlé
Bruno Kettel c'est très très présent on
a l'impression qu'un peu comme dans les
gilets jaunes et qui avait commencé sur
une question économique la taxe carbone
la question du pouvoir d'achat il y a eu
ensuite des questions démocratiques sur
le RIC là encore dans ce mouvement on
entend monter la volonté d'être associé
en tout cas la question démocratique est
centrale comment on fait sans faire de
gadgets comme la convention citoyenne
comment comment on remet le citoyen au
cœur de la décision je crois qu'il faut
absolument réfléchir sur nos
institutions qui ne sont plus adaptées à
l'esprit de actuel elles ont été
inventées en 1958 pour une raison qui a
dit tout à l'heure elles ont été
rénovées en dernier lieu en 2008 et le
président de la République a proposé de
le réformer sans succès il est temps je
crois de ce que nous fassions à un
consensus pour ceux qui ne va pas et
comment améliorer les choses parce que
effectivement on va pas pouvoir
continuer comme ça encore quatre ans et
puis peut-être le quinquennat suivant
donc il faut que des consensuelles se
dégagent c'est peut-être difficile mais
c'est tout à fait nécessaire parce que
autrement on en arrive aux situations de
blocage qu'on connaît aujourd'hui ou en
réalité une minorité de
d'électeurs et d'électrices parviennent
à faire élire une majorité même relative
à l'Assemblée nationale et ce système
n'est pas satisfaisant
vous permettez moi je crois qu'il y a
aussi une défiance aujourd'hui très
forte envers l'État les institutions on
le voit avec l'explosion de de
l'abstention et en fait si on ne
comprend pas que ce rejet c'est parce
que la Cinquième République est vécue
comme trop verticale parce donc si on
prend pas à bras le corps cette question
les institution tout de suite on risque
à mon sens de provoquer plutôt un choc
autoritaire et aujourd'hui les
instruments de la Cinquième République
si c'était dans les mains du
rassemblement national pour nommé je
pense que ce serait catastrophique pour
pour la question démocratique donc je
pense qu'il y a vraiment une urgence
tout de suite dans les mois qui viennent
à remettre cette question de la sur la
table Montesquieu disait il faut que par
un disposition des choses beaucoup les
Français absolument souvent les gens le
pouvoir arrête le pouvoir il faut
rappeler cette phrase de Montesquieu
parce que on a besoin de ça face à une
montée de l'autoritarisme pas uniquement
en France un peu partout en Europe c'est
pas une exception française et donc il
faut qu'on ait des systèmes qui soient
résilients par rapport à ça ça me semble
être un argument très important ça parce
que j'entends la question de
l'efficacité de la stabilité de
l'exécutif mais on a en France un régime
qui donne un pouvoir extraordinairement
grand à l'exécutif même le prix pour le
Casca pourra me contredire si j'ai une
bêtise mais même le président américain
n'a pas autant de pouvoir que le
président français au-dessus du
président français il y a quasiment que
les dictateurs qui est encore davantage
de pouvoir et donc effectivement ça va
bien tant que nous avons un président
issue d'un parti démocratique qui peut
manier ces instruments avec une certaine
forme d'hygiène comme le direct
Christophe Barbier mais que se
passerait-il si demain nous avions un
président ou une présidente qui serait
issue d'un parti non démocratique
en France si votre question est de
savoir si je crains que Marie Le Pen
soit élu en 2027 la réponse est oui
maintenant je crois quelle que soit la
nature du régime il faut aussi ramener
les citoyens et les citoyens dans leur
exercice du droit démocratique parce
qu'on voit beaucoup de gens lutter
contre l'abstention puis rappeler chacun
sa responsabilité de citoyens et
lecteurs contribuables voilà je veux
dire quoi les appeler alors
responsabilités
aux scrutin et et donc prennent toutes
leurs parts de responsabilité dans les
champs c'est difficile de contraindre
dans notre pays peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs même si le régime apparaît à
certains plus autoritaires qu'ailleurs
mais on a une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui à s'émanciper de cette
question qui est que plus de 50% des
Françaises et des Français ne se
déplacent pas pour des élections
nationales merci qu'on peut pas
continuer comme ça merci beaucoup
stevoire la visite du roi Charles à
Paris a été reporté voilà pas de grand
dîner d'État avec Versailles sa
manifestement était devenu intenable
merci infiniment d'être venu débattre
François Germaine vous restez avec moi
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
prit de nos affranchis vous les voyez ce
soir c'est Bertrand Perrier au centre
qui va interroger ou réinterroger la
petite phrase présidentielle sur la
foule et le peuple exécutif c'est le mot
de la semaine de notre sémiologue
Mariette darrigran et puis Elsa mon
Agava nous parlera de la loi immigration
vendue à la découpe mais d'abord
François Germaine on va plonger dans
dans le rapport du GIEC le dernier
rapport de synthèse des 93 scientifiques
du gied je le disais il est implacable
mais il y a quand même une note d'espoir
on voit ça dans l'invitation de Marco
pommier
si on vous invite François Gmail c'est
parce que l'avenir de la planète nous
inquiète le nouveau constat du rapport
du GIEC auquel vous avez participé est
implacable on n'est pas du tout sur la
bonne trajectoire alerte les experts du
climat le changement climatique est une
menace pour le bien-être de l'humanité
et la santé de la planète il existe une
fenêtre d'opportunités pour garantir un
avenir vivable et durable pour tous qui
se ferme rapidement nombre du GIEC
François Jemen vous êtes aussi
politologue chercheur spécialiste des
migrations environnementales vos alertes
et vos réflexions vous les avez
synthétisés vulgarisés dans plusieurs
ouvrages pour vous le déclic climatique
s'étend 2001 une rencontre dans un
ascenseur des Nations Unies avec
l'ambassadeur du tout-value son pays
affronte la montée des eaux et pourrait
être rayé de la carte et qu'on réaliste
rare intellectuelle à cet engagé en
politique vous conseiller deux candidats
à la président Benoît Hamon 2017 puis
Yannick Jadot en 2022 on ne vous y
reprendra plus on voit qu'on parvient
pas à rassembler une majorité autour
d'une action radicale et engagée pour le
climat et pourtant François Germaine il
y a urgence le changement climatique
s'observe partout dans le monde y
compris en France sécheresse hivernale
méga feu incontrôlable inondation les 10
prochaines années seront cruciales
rappelle le rapport du GIEC un véritable
manuel de survie de l'humanité à
destination de nos décideurs mais
l'écologie politique transformatrice
est-elle possible en démocratie
dites-nous François gemaine peut-on
vraiment s'en sortir vous le vénère de
l'écologie vous le désespérez du climat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est mort depuis la sortie du
troisième rapport du GIEC alors ce soir
François Germaine notre question paraît
évidente est-ce que c'est toujours mort
[Musique]
réponse François Gmail c'est mort pour
certains c'est mort pour certaines
choses
c'est mort pour certaines populations
aujourd'hui qui voit concrètement leur
lieu d'habitation disparaître et qui
sont contraintes à l'exil c'est mort
pour certaines espèces qui qui ne
réapparaîtront pas c'est mort pour les
glaciers de montagne c'est mort pour
toute une série d'écosystèmes qui ne
pourront pas survivre en tout cas pas en
tant que tel au dessus d'un degré 5 et
donc il faut quelque part faire son
deuil du monde tel qu'on le connaissait
avant il faut faire son deuil d'un
climat caractérisé par une grande
stabilité et se rendre compte qu'on
arrive dans une époque complètement
nouvelle que des adaptation en fait ça
veut dire qu'il faut quelque part
accepter effectivement que une série
d'impacts du changement climatique sont
irréversibles et qu'il va falloir s'y
adapter alors moi il reste plein de
choses à sauver c'est pas mort pour tout
ni pour tout le monde mais effectivement
il faut faire son deuil d'un certain
nombre de choses le rapport dit une
chose très c'est qu'au fond maintenant
les décideurs ont tout en main
c'est-à-dire que on a les outils
technologiques on a les solutions on a
les constats et pourtant on n'y arrive
pas la faute à qui c'est le manque de
volonté politique à l'échelle de la
planète aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a
une certaine forme de prise de
conscience réelle je pense qu'il y a une
certaine forme de volonté politique qui
s'exprime dans certains secteurs dans
certains pays mais on voit bien que
globalement on y arrive pas je pense
qu'on n'y arrive pas parce qu'on ne
parvient pas suffisamment à coopérer
ensemble et parce que chacun va
poursuivre son intérêt national avant de
poursuivre un intérêt global qui par
nature dépasserait l'intérêt frontières
et aussi parce que je crois dans la
société beaucoup de gens voient encore
le changement climatique comme une sorte
de cause à laquelle ils sont sensibles
qu'il est tracassent comme on peut être
tracassé par la fin dans le monde ou par
les droits humains mais pas comme
quelque chose qui touche directement à
leurs intérêts or il faut bien
reconnaître que c'est nos intérêts qui
nous font agir les 10 ans qui viennent
le rapport dit qu'elles sont cruciales
sinon quoi parce que on parle aussi des
une feuille de rupture c'est quelque
chose qui peut arriver vraiment sans
tomber dans le catastrophisme absolument
essayer de rupture les seuils de rupture
ce sont des moments où le climat va
passer brutalement d'un état vers un
autre sans qu'il soit plus vraiment
possible de faire quoi que ce soit pour
l'arrêter c'est comme si vous poussiez
un rocher sur le flanc d'une montagne
que le se Rocher vous obstrue
complètement la vue vous savez qu'au
moment où vous arriverez au sommet de la
montagne le rocher va dévaler l'autre
versant sans que vous puissiez l'arrêter
mais pour autant comme il vous obstrue
la vue vous ne savez pas exactement où
se trouve le sommet de la montagne ce
sommet pour les séducteur climatique
c'est 2 degrés il faut bien comprendre
que on atteindra forcément les un degré
et demi c'est ça entre 2030 et 2035
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 1,2
degrés d'élévation de la température
moyenne mondiale tous les 10 ans ça
augmente d'environ 0,2 degrés donc on y
sera vers 2035 je dirais oui
l'intégralité du changement climatique
est dû aux activités humaine il faut
bien le répéter
les 70
d'abord c'est important de le répéter
parce que beaucoup de gens y compris des
gens préoccupés par le changement
climatique qui nous écoutent qui nous
regardent en ce moment pense encore et
les sondages le montrent que seul 43%
des Français en fait sont convaincus de
du constat scientifique selon lequel le
changement climatique est rituel est
totalement imputable aux activités
humaines beaucoup pensent encore qu'il y
a une part de cycles naturels là-dedans
ce n'est pas le cas et donc il faut le
redire maintenant pour venir votre
question quelles sont les secteurs à
décarboner en priorité si on regarde la
France le principal poste d'émission ce
sont les transports et en particulier le
transport routier donc la question de la
décarbonation de la route ça doit être
une priorité ensuite arrive trois
secteurs un peu en dessous de 20% à peu
près à part égale c'est l'industrie
c'est l'agriculture et c'est le logement
et je voudrais tendance à dire que la
rénovation thermique des logements c'est
vraiment un investissement que peut
faire maintenant les pouvoirs publics
parce que il faut aussi un objectif
social un objectif d'équité donc ça va
avoir forcément tous ces secteurs
il était économiques comment on
accompagne comment on fait pour ne pas
détruire des portiers d'emploi est-ce
que ça aussi ça n'est que dans les mains
des décideurs est-ce que les démocraties
sont capables de répondre à ces
questions là pas suffisamment vite moi
je crois qu'on attend trop de décideurs
politiques et une sorte de tendance qui
me semble aussi particulièrement
française et en lien avec le débat qu'on
vient d'avoir à tout attendre de
l'exécutive comme s'il exécutif allait
pouvoir décider de tout actionner tous
les leviers en réalité énormément de
leviers qu'on peut actionner dans la
société la démocratie c'est pas juste le
président ce sont aussi les
collectivités c'est aussi la société
civile évidemment les entreprises quand
je regarde la société française
aujourd'hui c'est quand même dans les
entreprises dans les collectivités que
j'observe le plus de changements et j'ai
l'impression que le politique
globalement et notamment l'exécutif est
en retard sur la société le plus urgent
aussi c'est l'eau il y a 19 endroits sur
la planète où il y a plus de nappes
phréatiques en Inde en Chine en Amérique
du Nord dans la pénins arabique en fait
c'est toute l'alimentation mondiale qui
va être impactée c'est toute la
consommation c'est toute la production
agricole aussi bien sûr parce que nous
changeons nous passons d'une époque de
l'abondance on considère que les
ressources étaient illimitées c'était le
cas de l'eau c'était le cas des terres
agricoles c'était le cas du carbone ou
quelque part on ne se tracassait pas des
quantités consommées et nous passons à
une époque où le ressources vont être
raréfiées soit qu'il va falloir les
restreindre c'est le cas de l'usage du
carbone soit qu'elles vont être
raréfiées par les effets du changement
climatique et donc ça implique de on y
est quoi concrètement cet été en France
on pourra pas manger tous les fruits
qu'on veut on pourra pas à utiliser
l'eau comme on veut il y aura forcément
des coupures il faudra
forcément des choix politiques qui
devront être faits sur les questions
d'allocations des ressources
c'est-à-dire comment est-ce qu'on
partage équitablement une ressource qui
est raréfiée et s'il y a pas
ces choix politiques sur la question des
allocations on va avoir de plus en plus
de tensions et de violences dans la
société on observe pour le moment avec
les bassines dans les Deux-Sèvres c'est
quoi le problème c'est que des
agriculteurs décident de conserver de
l'eau de pluie ce qui peut sembler être
une décision de bon sens mais d'autres
si opposent parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que les agriculteurs se
réservent une ressource rare pour
eux-mêmes sans la partager avec le reste
des utilisateurs vous allez très loin
dans le rapport parce que vous dites
bien sûr il y a un changement total dans
les comportements mais les pays les
nations vont devoir et notamment les
démocraties remettre en cause leur
principe fondamentaux la souveraineté la
liberté et l'égalité ça veut dire quoi
on va devenir quoi des pays autoritaires
parce qu'il faudra se contraindre
comment vous voyez les choses la liberté
notamment toutes nos économies et donc
toutes nos démocraties sont profondément
enchassés dans les énergies fossiles et
s'il est tellement difficile d'en sortir
parce qu'il s'agit pas juste de
remplacer une énergie par une autre il
s'agit de repenser non seulement la
manière dont on va produire et consommer
certains biens mais aussi la manière
dont comme vous le disiez on va
envisager certains des concepts qui sont
fondateurs de nos sociétés la
souveraineté qu'est-ce que ça veut
encore dire la souveraineté nationale
lorsque le futur climatique de la France
lorsque les impacts la température qu'il
fera en France ne dépend pas du tout des
actions prises par le gouvernement
français qu'est-ce que ça veut encore
dire la liberté est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
accepter de restreindre certaines
libertés individuelles pour garantir
l'exercice de certaines libertés
collectives qu'est-ce qu'on accepte de
se mettre comme restriction la question
de la restriction de vitesse sur les
routes est un bel exemple par exemple
mais vous pensez qu'il faut les poser de
façon très concrète dans des politiques
publiques où il faut déjà préparer les
esprits pour que des consensus des
accords se dégagent parce que on n'a pas
l'impression que dans les démocraties
qui réalise leur chef tous les 5 ans de
tels de tels sacrifice possible
certainement pas c'est pour ça que je
crois qu'il faut absolument
préparer une certaine forme de consensus
social si ces mesures sont imposées de
façon autoritaire d'abord ça sera un
déni démocratie mais surtout elles ne
sont pas acceptées par la population il
faudra un moment donné les abandonner ce
qui sera pire que tout pour le
changement climatique parce que nous
allons le voir gouverner ce climat
jusqu'au au moins la moitié du 22e
siècle et donc il va falloir que nous
choisissions collectivement ce que nous
voulons faire et c'est vraiment
important que la question de la lutte
contre le changement climatique nous
nous apparaissent plus comme une
contrainte qui nous tombe dessus comme
une série d'efforts de sacrifices que
personne ne veut vraiment consentir mais
comme un vrai projet social et
démocratique qui nous emmène vers
l'avant on parle des retraites on parle
aussi d'immigration en ce moment vous
trouvez qu'on n'a pas du tout mis le
climat sur toutes les politiques
publiques la question démocratique n'est
pas posée la question migratoire et du
climat n'est pas posée ça devrait être
présent de façon systémique dans toutes
les décisions on raisonne encore comme
si le climat était un problème à part
qu'on allait pouvoir traiter à part avec
certaines mesures alors qu'en réalité
toutes les grands sujets politiques
économiques et sociaux du 21e siècle
vont être complètement transfigurés par
la question climatique sur la question
des retraites on s'appuie sur des
scénarios de projection démographique
qui tiennent absolument pas compte de la
manière dont le changement climatique va
perturber nos projections d'espérance de
vie va amener certaines migrations et
donc potentiellement de nouveaux
contributeurs au système des retraites
on va voir un XM projet sur l'asile et
l'immigration qu'il a encore ne va rien
dire du tout de la manière dont le
climat vont transformer les flux
migratoires quand même à mettre le
climat dans dans toutes les politiques
publiques et il a des bons élèves où
c'est je dirais qu'il y a des élèves qui
sont moins mauvais que d'autres et
effectivement il y a des pays notamment
les pays scandinaves consident souvent
mais aussi un pays comme la
Nouvelle-Zélande et j'ai envie de dire
surtout les pays du Sud c'est à dire
ceux qui sont les plus touchés
directement par les impacts du
changement climatique aux Bangladesh le
climat il est présent dans toutes les
politiques
la grande question de l'équité en gros
les populations les plus riches sont les
plus émettrices les populations les plus
pauvres sont les victimes du
réchauffement comment on va réussir à
gérer cette question de la justice qui
semble abyssale non seulement les plus
pauvres sont les premières victimes mais
en plus nous sommes en train de leur
dire surtout n'utilisez pas vos énergies
fossiles parce que si vous le faites
alors même que ces énergies pour le
moment sont nécessaires pour leur
développement et pour la richesse du
pays si vous le faites vous allez
envoyer tout le monde dans le mur et
donc effectivement on ne s'en sort pas
pour le moment et chacun reste concentré
sur ses propres émissions de gaz effet
de serre alors que le climat se fiche
éperdument évidemment que les émissions
viennent de l'immap de Bangkok ou de
Paris dernière question donnez-nous un
peu d'espoir quand même
Dubaï pour la cop28 ça donne espoir ou
pas c'est très étrange ce choix
en fait je sais que c'est une réflexion
un peu iconoclaste mais l'enjeu c'est
fondamentalement la question des
énergies fossiles
ça fait 25 ans qu'on tourne autour du
pot qu'on fait des conférences entre
pays vertueux à Copenhague ou à Paris en
essayant d'éviter la question quelque
part porter la coop à Dubaï c'est aussi
porter le fer dans les plaies et prendre
le taureau par les cornes parce que il
va bien falloir discuter avec les pays
qui ont construit toute leur économie
sur l'exploitation des énergies fossiles
de ce qu'on fait si on sort des énergies
fossiles merci beaucoup avec plaisir
français
de la pédagogie nous parler du dernier
rapport du GIEC dont vous êtes l'un des
principaux auteurs je crois que vous
devez nous quitter c'est bien dommage
parce que je vais accueillir les
affranchis à présent pour leur partie
prix venez les amis elles amont d'engava
Mariette darrêt grand et puis bien sûr
Bertrand Paris vous pouvez rester si
vous êtes pas trop pressé allez vous
rester super Bertrand Perrier vous nous
parlez ce soir de cette petite phrase
sur la foule et le peuple qui a fait
tant réagir et Mariette d'arrêt grand
vous nous parlez du mot exécutivement
finalement il nous a quitté au revoir
Françoise Lemaine hors caméra merci
d'accord et on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée par
Elsa mondain Gava bonsoir Elsa bonsoir
je vous raconte l'histoire d'un
saucissonnage je vous parle pas encore
de l'apéro de ce soir c'est un terme
dont on parle beaucoup en ce moment pour
évoquer une loi la loi immigration à
l'étain inscrite dès la semaine
prochaine en séance au Sénat sauf qu'à
la disparu de l'ordre du jour pour
certains elle est au mieux suspendue au
pire elle est morte et enterrée je vous
le rappelle que ce texte de loi devait
selon l'adage du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin est méchant avec les
méchants gentils avec les gentils un
volet pour favoriser l'expulsion des
étrangers délinquants ça c'est les
méchants un autre pour régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers notamment dans
les métiers en tension ça ce sont les
gentils alors pourquoi ça semble très
compliqué que cette loi revienne au
Parlement alors déjà même avant
l'épisode du 49-3 dans le groupe
Renaissance on n'était pas très chaud
pour après l'épisode des retraites
s'attaquer à un sujet aussi inflammable
et puis surtout 49-3 qui oblige
gouvernement du se rendre compte qu'il
n'y avait pas de majorité pour vos tests
pourquoi parce que les mesures de droite
et bien elles rebutent la gauche et
inversement trop de fermeté pour les uns
trop d'humanité pour les autres et c'est
pas franchement dans l'idée dans l'air
du temps de refaire passer une loi avec
le 49-3 et là je vous dis et bien vous
allez me dire Myriam est-ce que le
gouvernement enterré le projet de loi
non c'est pas si simple que ça puisqu'on
le sait manuel Macron il veut parler du
régalien il sait qu'on lui reproche
parfois de manquer de fermeté dans ce
domaine et puis il y en a un autre qui
pousse évidemment pour que le sujet soit
reste sur la table c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur lui-même Gérald Darmanin
invitait ce matin sur cnews d'abord
c'est un texte très important qui est
très populaire tous les sondages du
monde 2000 intérieur préfère toujours
que ce soit un seul texte bien
évidemment mais il appartient à la
première ministre et au président de
chambre d'avoir la bonne discussion la
nouvelle méthode comme évoquée le
président de la République et moi je me
rongerai à leur proposition l'important
pour le ministre intérieur que je suis
pour les Français c'est un texte ferme
contre l'immigration irrégulière Gérald
Darmanin qui a énormément consulter reçu
des parlementaires de tout bord pour
préparer sa loi pour lui ça allait être
un moment politique évidemment important
et on sait que ça compte pour un
ministre qui a beaucoup d'ambition alors
comment on en sort quelle solution
possible et bien c'est là qu'intervient
la technique du saucissonnage on peut
faire passer un bout de la loi par le
groupe les républicains par exemple qui
pourraient proposer un texte sur
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants
pourquoi pas reprendre une proposition
loi dans des groupes de la majorité sur
l'intégration regardez aussi ce qui peut
être fait du domaine de réglementaire
mais tout ça ça nous laisse dans le loi
dans la loi que les dispositions sur le
droit d'asile on est bien loin d'une
grande loi mais c'est peut-être ça
finalement la nouvelle méthode à
laquelle va devoir se résoudre le
gouvernement des lois fabriquées en
fonction des opportunités politiques à
condition que les députés de chaque
groupe je vous le jeu exactement sachant
que ça risque d'être compliqué à droite
mais peut-être qu'on pourrait faire un
coup à droite un coup à gauche un coup
au milieu et le risque c'est zigzaguer
aussi un au niveau de la cohérence
politique Bertrand Perrier découpé comme
ça un texte vous croyez que ça peut
marcher à l'Assemblée alors ça peut
marcher politiquement après la question
est de savoir si ça passe aussi le cap
du Conseil constitutionnel parce qu'il y
a une sorte de détournement aussi des
règles qui encadre le
dialogue entre les parlementaires et je
trouve étonnant que l'on saucissonne un
peu un texte au gré des majorités on va
sur votre chronique j'ai plus de
questions surprise la foule n'a pas de
légitimité face au peuple cette phrase a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre elle a été
prononcée par le chef de l'État dans le
huis clos de l'Élysée Emmanuel Macron
qui recevait sa majorité avant son
interview sur TF1 France 2 qu'est-ce que
vous en avez pensé c'est évidemment une
phrase étonnante parce que cette
distinction entre la foule et le peuple
n'est pas très intuitive et d'ailleurs
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a réagi à cette
distinction en disant la foule est au
peuple ce que le cri est à la voix en
réalité c'est une distinction assez
ancienne Aristote connaissait déjà
puisque il distinguait le peuple demos
qui donnera démocratie de la foule
pléthos qui donnera pléthorique et les
anciens avaient même théorisé un cycle
des régimes politiques dans lequel la
démocratie le pouvoir du peuple pourrait
sombrer dans un autre régime le pouvoir
de la foule l'ocratie lorsque on oublie
le sens de l'intérêt général alors
quelle distinction précise la différence
entre la foule et la différence elle
pourrait se résumer par une phrase de
Victor Hugo qui faisait déjà cette
différence et qui dit le peuple étant
haut et la foule est en bas le peuple ce
serait un corps social organisé
rationnel mesuré éclairer respectueux
des institutions et à l'inverse la foule
ce serait un magma un contrôle un peu
égaré un peu violent qui serait soumis à
tous les embrigadements possibles à
toutes les passions et vulnérables à la
démagogie et ça renvoie ouvrage
fondamental de la fin du 19e siècle qui
s'appelle psychologie des foules d'un
sociologue qui s'appelle Gustave Lebon
et qui montre que en réalité la foule
prise comme un ensemble à une
psychologie propre distincte des
individus qui la composent que des
individus feraient inclus dans une foule
des choses qu'il serait incapable de
faire s'ils ne sont pas dans la foule
que il y aurait dans la foule une
proportion à la contagion d'une forme de
violence et que la foule pourrait être
hypnotisée par des raters très
convaincants et donc finalement pour
dire les choses un peu rapidement un
individu dans une foule redeviendrait un
acte à un être primitif donc elle est
lourde de sens politique cette
distinction opérée par Emmanuel Macron
évidemment il y a là une volonté de
disqualifier par le mot la le mouvement
social le mouvement populaire qui donc
serait le fait d'individus inconséquent
des métiers perdus dans une action
irrationnelle et poursuivant des
intérêts propres et
ignorants de l'intérêt général et que
seul vaudrait par contraste le peuple
qui serait ceux qui jouerait le jeu de
la démocratie représentative si je peux
avoir un avis là-dessus je suis assez
réservé je crois l'opposition un peu
simpliste est-ce que le seul fait de
protester pour des raisons tout de même
assez claires et argumentés contre un
projet tel que celui de la réforme des
retraites suffirait à faire des
manifestants une simple foule que l'on
pourrait ignorer au contraire est-ce que
les manifestants quelle que soit leur
indiscipline ou leur débordement ne
pourrait pas avoir un corpus idéologique
des revendications politiques qui sont
les caractéristiques d'un peuple
la rue a une place en démocratie elle
n'a pas toute la place mais elle a une
place et exclure du peuple ce qui
exprime leur inquiétude dans la rue
c'est tout de même faire prévaloir une
vision assez réductrice du peuple et
peut-être même d'une foule une foule
sentimentale qui a soif d’idéal quelle
chute merci pour le clin d'oeil à
Souchon et vous pouvez toujours dans ces
cartes blanches et mettre un avis comme
vous dites Mariette merci pour cette
carte blanche on parle d'un mot que vous
allez choisir qui est passionnant
exécutif c'est le mot de la semaine
oui Myriam parce que c'est un mot qui a
remplacé ce qu'on disait auparavant
c'est-à-dire la présidence ou le Premier
ministre les gouvernants et alors depuis
quelques années on dit plus ça on dit
l'exécutif et c'est venu du votre monde
c'est venu des journalistes ce sont les
journalistes qui ont imposé cette
formule le couple exécutif souvent des
voilà et je crois qu'il s'agit d'un
grand remplacement symbolique très
important pourquoi alors pourquoi ce
succès de ce mot plutôt technique
d'ailleurs c'est un mot voilà qui vient
de la langue technique
institutionnelle on pourrait dire alors
qui est venu par les médias de gauche
mon diplôme Mediapart et qui aujourd'hui
est partout Figaro le monde les échos
ici même à partir un mot image vous nous
dites alors c'est un mot qui est très
simple d'une certaine façon il est très
technique institutionnelle mais il est
simple et surtout voilà c'est un mot
image image visuelle et image sonore
quand on l'entend on voit quelque chose
donc quand on entend exécutif on voit
tout de suite la guillotine sur la place
de notre cerveau imaginaire analogique
va extrêmement vite donc Victor Hugo
donc de la Croix la Liberté guidant le
peuple sur les barricades parce que au
final c'est ça qu'on a en ce moment
c'est à dire on veut exécuter l'exécutif
parce qu'on se sent exécuté par lui
voilà le cercle digne en même temps
exécutif il y a aussi un sens plus
positif on parle d'exécuter une danse on
parle d'exécutive woman il n'y a pas que
cette idée d'un coup près le mot est
très positif au départ en fait il s'agit
c'est quoi en latin c'est suivre de
suivre d'aller au bout d'une tâche donc
il est positif il est consciencieux
effectivement par exemple le producteur
en cinéma il y a le producteur qui met
de l'argent et le producteur exécutif il
veille à ce que l'argent soit bien
utilisé qu'on aille au bout du tournage
et en politique c'est la même idée il
faut aller au bout du processus
évidemment en équilibre avec le pouvoir
législatif et le pouvoir judiciaire mais
le problème c'est qu'il y a aussi tout
d'un coup exécuter un prisonnier
par exemple donc c'est le sens négatif
qui aujourd'hui émerge ça veut dire la
crise des retraites faire quelque chose
de bien mais ça veut dire tuer et je
crois que c'est ce sens là c'est
connotation là qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui ce double sens du mot cette
ambivalence c'est une enfymologie comme
on dit cuistrement c'est un mot qui va
comme les choses qui les animaux qui
sont en phobie donc on peut marcher sur
la terre positive avec ce mot et sur la
terre négative donc si vous laissez tout
ça qui se réveille avec une
cristallisation sur notre président bien
sûr il y avait déjà eu le premier match
de des gilets jaunes contre l'exécutif
qui veut nous exécuter en augmentant le
prix du carburant et là avec les
retraites ce qui m'a frappé c'est quand
même le vocabulaire de la mort qui est
venu le terme assassin est venu dans
l'hémicycle et puis même sur les
pancartes des manifestants vous voyez
métro boulot caveau métro boulot tombeau
c'est à dire là on évoque la mort
alors vous allez me dire c'est le
langage il est comme ça on exagère
toujours etc mais je crois que si il
faut faire très attention aux
connotation aux connotations négatives
elles font des choses si j'ose dire en
notre absence elle crée des effets donc
ça met de la morbidité dans l'air tout
ça et ça nous rappelle qu'à l'origine
dans le monde romain les cérémonies
exécutives en fait c'était des
processions funèbres ce que l'on suivait
jusqu'au bout et bien c'était les morts
voilà donc il y a ce sens dans notre
mémoire je vais réfléchir deux fois
quand j'utiliserai ce terme désormais
merci beaucoup Mariette c'était
passionnant merci Bertrand on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine Elsa
fidèle au poste bien sûr très belle
soirée c'est le week-end profitez bien
et restez sur SCP fidèle bien sûr
[Musique]